you
[Music]
so it's my pleasure to introduce the
agent joy who's an associate professor
at the University of Washington and also
a senior research manager ai2
she's done a number of really
interesting research projects over the
year it's always fun to watch what you a
gin has been doing including things
about common sense knowledge or language
generation and more recently about AI
for social good and she's had a number
of really an impressive accolades
including like the top ten to watch in
2015 from AI Tripoli's AI and recipient
of the Marr prize in ICCB and also a
member of the team that won the Alexa
prize challenge in 2017 so lots of
amazing things to walk watch for and so
alright speaking of Alex surprise
challenge start by sharing brief
experience with this so the goal of this
challenge was to create conversational
AI that can make a coherent and engaging
conversation with humans and the good
news is that the team that I was part of
thanks to the amazing students we won
the competition and he felt it great to
be the winner the bad news is that
conversational AI remains to be more or
less unsolved
so especially to our surprise who were
not a surprising factor at all is that
the winning recipe was not based on
neural networks with the brute force
more data deeper networks and spikes
spiked with the reinforcement learning
that just didn't work so now that's
curious why why would that be because we
we thought that neural networks do
amazing things like superhuman
performance on object recognition or
image captioning a lot of Industry
replacing their long-standing
statistical machine translation systems
with the neural melt models and then of
course a special recognition has been
working really well and even more
recently human level performance on
reading comprehension Wow and all these
are based on very large amount of
training data and then sufficiently deep
networks so this should work
however if
we look at closely there are significant
performance gaps across different types
of tasks so first of all nobody is
really reporting on superhuman
performance on making a conversation or
summarizing a document or composing an
email on behalf of me or identifying
fake news despite the fact that we have
a lot of data for all of this or if not
me at least companies do have a lot of
data for any of this and they do have a
lot of GPUs too so why is it that we
don't hear about this from the news and
even for those applications for which
neural networks do perform at superhuman
level for some datasets they usually are
never robust if given unfamiliar out of
the domain or adversarial example as
Yonatan was talking about this morning
so what's going on here I'm going to
argue that in fact that's because they
are very fundamentally two different
types of applications out there and we
are primarily seeing the advancements
for type one type tasks where shallow
understanding can get you quite far so
an example is translating bananas are
green in English sentence into a Polish
sentence
banana song Jelani for this neural
networks are very good at learning word
level or phrase level pattern matching
so that it can learn to translate from
one language to the other without really
understand much about a particular
language whereas if I were to make a
conversation and tell you bananas are
green you might tell me no they're not
or you might tell me they're not ripe
and if we try to learn the mapping
function between input-output pairings
this way there's only a very weak
alignment between the input and output
and in fact we need some sort of
abstraction cognition or reasoning in
order to really know what to say next
and so it which in turn requires
knowledge especially common sense
knowledge and
ignoring this factor all together and
try to learn this mapping function just
doesn't make a lot of a sense so to make
another point about how important it is
to be able to read between the lines and
let's think about news headline
cheeseburger stabbing if you give this
to state of the art parser today it's
going to tell you that cheeseburger is a
noun
modifying another word the stabbing
which may be a noun or verb depending on
which parser you use but it doesn't
matter the fact that one word modifying
the other doesn't tell us whether it
means someone stepped a cheeseburger or
a cheeseburger step two salmon or a
cheeseburger step to another
cheeseburger and so forth and you know
what may have been the actual meaning of
this news headline because you're able
to fill in this missing information from
the sentence so that there are probably
two people involved in this act even
though they were not even mentioned in
the original news headline and when we
do do that it's the common sense
knowledge that we rely on especially
physical common sense is that it's not
possible to step somebody you using a
cheeseburger because it's too soft and
standing someone is not good and it's
immoral so it's more likely to be
newsworthy
whereas if you step a cheeseburger who
cares so when we look at and think about
different types of knowledge in fact
there has been tremendous amount of
research if we're learning and
extracting encyclopedic knowledge like
who is the president of which country
and born it what year but not knowing
this I can make a fairly okay
conversation however it's really common
sense knowledge that we need in order to
make an okay conversation so these novel
physics technology were social norms
have not been studied very much and if
you look up a CL anthology so this is as
we all know the repository of NLP papers
most papers that dare to mention the
world common sense are either from 80s
who were from the past few years so
nothing in between complete void
and I think it's imperfect color so
there was tremendous failure with the
common sense in 80s and so but recently
simply that people start to forgetting
about the path to failure so there's
been I feel very interesting datasets
one of which is from Microsoft test
whether Rock story common sense dataset
and so for all of these tasks basically
just grow force more data larger
networks don't really go very far and we
somehow need a different game plan so to
be honest I don't really know what what
there should be but for lack of any
better idea I'm going to talk about two
different directions a thinking about
neural network architectures they can
better model the latent process in our
mind when understanding and reasoning
about text abstracting away from the
surface patterns and then simultaneously
we might want to think more about
representation formalisms
orthogonal to neural networks and really
think about how can we possibly organize
and learn common-sense knowledge using
language as a scaffoldings now usually
in this spectrum I talk about these
three pieces shown here but the second
one will be described by Antoine today
so I'm going to only give you teaser for
that and instead talk about dynamic
entities in your own language models so
let's begin with the first part
so neural checklist model was originally
designed to think about particular kind
of language generation challenge in
particular there are three different
types of a generation setting case one
is a small input small output like
machine translation case two is a big
input small output like document
isomerization and these are two cases
have you been studied a lot more in in
the past
whereas case three is the case when
there may be only very sketchy input
small input and then suddenly we have to
generate
the bigger output and for this there are
two unique challenges a there's an
information gap so the machine has to
have a creative power to fill in a lot
of information that was not even quite
in the input and then the second
challenge is that the moment you start
generating more than one sentence it's
very very easy to make problems so
coherence becomes a big challenge as
well so a little bit more formally the
task that we are going to think about
momentarily is that there's going to be
an input which is the title and on
agenda which is a list of items that you
want to talk about and then the output
will be a paragraph or a document with
the multiple sentences that tries to
achieve the goal employed by the title
and then try to make use of only and all
of the agenda items and for now we are
going to use a recipe generation as a
running task running example but later
the model will be applied to this
dialogue response generation as well so
at the beginning we thought that in
order to generate recipe we should first
parse it because that's what a lot of
people do in an LP once we parse it we
are going to abstract away some
[Music]
prototypical graph structure out of it
from which perhaps we can sample a graph
which is like planning and then convert
to that graph down to raw text so there
was our original plan and we even worked
on the first two segments and managed to
write a paper about parsing recipes into
action graphs but then it realized we
realized that doing this entire salt
call is quite hard because errors
started propagating it's really it was
really unclear what to do with this I'm
still wanting to do this but in the
meanwhile we were wondering whether we
could somehow simplify the whole process
and that's when we heard about encoder
decoder architecture in neural network
literature which apparently were
creative
a lot of a task like machine translation
so let's encode the recipe title into a
vector and then decode the entire recipe
out and see what happens
sausage sandwiches so this is what
happens all right
I picked on purpose worst example
however recurrent in neural networks
tend to repeat itself a lot like a
sandwich a sandwich
eventually it over overcomes the
sandwich overdose but still things must
still be repeated that listed twice so
why does this not work very well for us
when it does really work really well for
a lot of other tasks well it doesn't
work well when there's only a very weak
alignment between the input and the
output that's what I was trying to tell
you earlier about different input-output
comparisons in this particular task only
6 to 10% of words in the output came
from the input which means 90 to 94
percent of the time Apple came out of
nothing almost it looks almost that way
for the neural networks or
encoder/decoder architecture so the rest
has to come from somewhere else and you
know network the the off-the-shelf
models don't operate very well so with
this in mind the high-level idea is that
is it possible to compose a neural
network architecture that could sort of
have this mental map of different items
that you might want to check as you go
so that's what we did with the neural
checklist model but since this one is a
little bit hard to stare at let's look
at much a simplified version as a fellow
so we're going to make garlic tomato
salsa based on this visualization where
we encode the title into vector there's
a checklist that has lists of agenda
items and then at each time step this is
one unit of some recurrent neural
network in our case it's a GRU but that
particular choice it doesn't matter
so in
journalist went to make this a three-way
decision whether I am about to generate
a word that is non ingredient word were
new ingredient word who were none of the
above so let's see how it works so let
us say so far we generally the chapter
internally the model was going to look
at its own context and decided at all
it's time to use one of the new items so
it's going to do softmax
over all the new items and then let's
say Tomatoes got the highest score so we
check that off from the checklist and
move forth so the second sentence might
start with the dice though and at this
point the network might internally
decide that oh let's use another unused
item and softmax will do the probability
projection only over the unused apart
and let's say onions were the second
best choice and check that off from the
checklist and move forward now something
interesting is about to happen so add to
it at this point contextually it's the
moment when you go back to one of the
already introduced items that's just how
the discourse queues are in the
indicating to us and that's also what
the network picks up as well so let's
you what should we use between tomatoes
and onions tomatoes because that's what
was introduced earlier on and the
discourse convention is that that's what
we do mention and the network learns to
do that so in fact all this checklist is
probabilistic and were this it's not
black and white so it's based on the
attend simulation of attention scores
which reflects how much the model thinks
that it made use of a particular
ingredient and then the three-way
classification is also soft in the sense
it's an interpolation of a three
different language model like components
where the first one is generic language
model like
ordinance or jurors oral STM's whereas
the other two are based on attention
mechanisms looking at either use the
portion or on use the portion of the
agenda item so we did comparisons
automatically and of course the stories
that we do better than other baselines
but the Machine tray so we borrowed
machine translation measures and when
you'll just look at this number looks
really very low so you probably want to
see actual samples so I'm going to show
you that but briefly this one shows what
fraction of agenda items the model is
making use of and the regular
encoder/decoder architecture with or
without attentions practically ignores
what's given in the input because they
are not very when the input/output
alignment is so weak they're not very
good at actually learning the mapping so
mostly they are ignored whereas
checklist can make use of much bigger
portion so example skillet chicken rice
baseline that's regular arenas in a
larger scale skillet brown chicken in
oil add chicken and rice cook and more
rice and broth and cook some more and so
forth so starting more rice is starting
more rice keep cooking and probably to
edible safe to eat in the end but
somehow there's not much of a coherence
so checklist on the other hand there's
much better job so in a largest skillet
hit rice and onion add carrots and
mushrooms cook stir constantly until hot
and bubbly stir in seasonings cook some
more stirring chicken and then cook some
more and then serve over rice
so overall the coherence suddenly became
much better even though in this model we
are not even doing any fancy modeling of
discourse in any measure but it was only
this checklist that is external memory
structure that allows recurrent neural
networks to better manage what's
happening in the long-term context and
that's going to be sort of a repeating
mess
in the first half of this talk so works
really well when the input is familiar
and apparently skillet chicken rice is
quite common recipe in the data set so
and this is a human recipe it's probably
a little bit better so let's look at the
failure case chocolate-covered the
potato chips now never heard of this
before
and baseline preheat over probably good
idea but then grease flour a pen start
to baking it right away
so because input is unfamiliar it
doesn't know what to do with this
just ignore it in the case of chocolate
it's paying more attention it also does
weird the thing like suddenly bake
something right away but then you'd
realized oh I haven't done anything with
chocolate so let's melt it and then it
says silly things like add the potato
mixture to the potato mixture which is
grammatically correct it's just a little
bit silly eventually it's going to fried
that in a hot oil and I don't think it's
a good idea to fry something covered in
melt to the chocolate so that says
something about AI safety and I'm not
joking here so the fundamental problem
with the neural networks today despite
all these amazing results is that they
struggle for unfamiliar input and as a
result you know we cannot really really
really really trust them so human recipe
is much better and I'm going to come
back to this point in a bit but let me
very briefly mention how the same model
was able to achieve better performance
on a particular dialogue response data
set as well so moving on to the teaser
of the neural process networks
which I'm going to only give you
motivation for so this is another
example globally cool here oh sorry
deep fry the cauliflower that was the
title and then neural checklist model
generate the following wash and
try the cauliflower heat the oil in the
skillet and fry the sauce until they're
golden brown
drain on paper towels add the sauce to
the sauce and mix well serve hot or cold
what's wrong with this
what's a cauliflower is a steer it's a
clean but hasn't been cooked yet so
again you know I mean against
cauliflower is okay to eat raw but so
when I gave this talk about neural
checklist model at Harvard University a
student asked me after the talk our
arena is a month without a brain and I
wasn't sure how to respond to that I
guess I sort of agreed with her so we
need common sense knowledge to reason
about this sort of unfamiliar situations
and humans can still do the right thing
whereas we don't know what's going what
machines will do you know networks will
do so that's sort of the motivation like
can we think about new architecture that
could read between the lines and reason
about the unspoken but obvious effects
like for example fright off in the pan
we know just common sense wise we know
that then location of tofu must be in
the pen and temperature of tofu must
become hot even though the sentence
doesn't say any of this so in a way it's
similar to how we might be able to do
mental simulation up about a lot of
things when we understand the stories
and understand others when making
conversation with them and in fact there
have been some literature in cognitive
science or psychology that that's what
humans seem to be doing exactly how he's
always debatable but we seem to be doing
something like this and so can me then
challenge ourself by asking this
question instead of this question so a
lot of NLP research has been based on
labeling let's label every word in a
sentence with the syntactic and semantic
categories and that has been really very
useful but it focuses by-and-large on
what is a set in
sentence can we also think about in
addition to that simulating the causal
effects that's obvious but not spoken
and abstracting away from the surface
strings and in fact there have been some
recent efforts of that flavor but of
course when people writing papers in at
the beginning no paper will solve
anything completely so we have another
one coming up your process Network you
can hear more about this in a bit today
but I will leave it there and then talk
about the next component dynamic
entities in neural language models so
that's work with other colleagues that
you don't do always here
I swear today and so the problem with
the neural networks this is another
sample that I found from a paper that
introduced Lambada data said I think so
human says what's your job motion says
I'm a lawyer
human says what do you do now motion
says I'm a doctor too so I mean somewhat
understandable if you think about how I
embedded here and I embedding here when
it starts with the word embedding it's
studying like at the same word it's the
same word and so Jane in Jane Eyre maybe
the same as Jane and Mentalist in terms
of how they start with neural
representation and then when I say she
it to mean Jane now suddenly they kind
of look like different words in addition
to that there's this so philosophical
question of is it possible to encode
very large context into one vector and
the Ray said no it's not possible I
don't know maybe some of you in the
audience who are very very young maybe
have not known about this but he said
that and I'm going to just repeat what
he said by adding that noir into a
sequence of vectors it's just not enough
so recurrent recurrent language model
has a sequence of vectors basically and
our model is to add more external
memory that can have a better long-term
representation as follows so let us say
this award is some entity and then I'm
going to create this a separate memory
chain which is also recurrent for some
time and whenever I see a new entity
mention I'm going to create a new chain
and they are going to be just copying
themselves over over time until there's
a core efference to the same blue entity
at which point I'm going to now combine
the context coming from the recurrent
neural network with whatever I was a
storing here as a separate memory chain
and so forth so that's the gist of this
model that let's have a separate chain
in which we store a little bit more
precise information about different and
dimensions corresponding to the same
entity and in doing so we are now sort
of having recurrent entity model in
addition to the recurrent language model
and whenever we need to compute new
entity embedding in this in this chain
we are going to interpolate that between
whatever was coming from the neural
network a language model part and then
whatever was stored here and that
interpolation is based on gating so
that's fairly standard thing to do and
the gating can be parameterized in many
different ways
this is a particular way of a
parameterizing it but it doesn't have to
be this way so once we have that then
what can we do with this well usually
when you sample words out it goes in
sequence in the language model part like
this and when we do that instead of
conditioning on just hidden state of the
recurrent neural network part now we can
condition also on whatever is relevant
to entity for that part by doing so we
just have a more precise con
turning on the context that is more
relevant than how we do they will be
impossible otherwise so it's just in
some sense I mean like feel for the
neural network with the two layers you
should be able to approximate anything
in theory but nobody can train it to do
anything useful and that's why in the
computer vision community we would be we
will be in saying a lot of our new
architectures like Reggie do net dense
net condensed net and so forth so
similarly I think we need to do more
research like this this may not be the
best architecture yet but there are the
kind of architecture that allows us to
carry on long-term context more
precisely so that's sort of the
intuition I'm going to give you just a
very brief intuition about what we do
for training and testing so we went with
this idea of a generative model such
that for each word there are a bunch of
bookkeeping variables that we create
such as a boolean variable that ask
whether currently on a part of an entity
or not and if so which entity am i
belong to do I belong to and then watch
the length and this there's this length
of that decrease over time until it hits
a zero it's one way to do that there may
be different ways of doing it and
finally core efference relations and
this one just shows how these variables
might refer to different information so
during training we are going to in this
work we'll just assume that we have this
perfect correct chain that was given
from the sky
that's probably unrealistic assumption
to make but as a first step that's what
we did and then during testing of course
we assumed a little bit less kosher to
assume that for testing so we just
sample and marginalize them out using
importance of sampling and by doing this
then what can we do we can we can then
think about different
use cases so we first of all looked at
just using this as a language model that
may be able to marginalize out different
types of occurrence decisions and then
in that case it can lower the perplexity
on the Conal test set and then in the
second case we also use the dis in order
to improve a certain core efference
resolution system that we could
piggyback on by adding our number our
scores at the model scores as additional
scores to help with rankings so we
plugged our system to ranking based
system and we were able to improve the
performance it's not state-of-the-art
because people keep improving on this
quite a bit and our colleague at YouTube
look has much stronger results now and
then finally there was also very
interesting new data set that was a
little bit common-sense inspired and it
was about predicting what entity may get
mentioned in extent for that task also
we were able to perform much better than
other strong baselines so that's another
story that sort of repeats this theme of
or spirit of having new neural network
architecture that might better
represents the latent the process that
goes in the way text is written where
text is understood and then now I'm
going to switch the gear quite a bit and
talk about this verb physics which is
more on this side so this work is sort
of motivated by this hope that in the
future we may have a home robot that
should understand a lot about different
household items so that it can interact
with them he should have understanding
about relative size weight rigidity
strength and so forth
so it's good to be aware that usually
people are larger than a chair and if I
were to look this up on go
nobody says this but now I said that so
you can search this but when I searched
it for the first time I couldn't search
that or any of this because nobody says
any of this it's trivially true so this
is a known fact as the reporting bias
that people don't state the obvious
and then when finally people say
something
it's like exceptional case so we must
now conclude that horses are similar in
size to dogs so then what do we do I
thought that the answer must be in
computer vision let's look at images so
we worked on this and one of the papers
looked at lots of images and estimated
relative size the differences are
adjusted where the depth the difference
is and then we were able to learn some
knowledge like dogs are usually bigger
than cats but the takeaway from this
work was that I thought and now peas are
very hard but computer vision is also
hard and in addition to that computer
vision just takes more computation
because images are bigger to process so
after producing processing lots of
images I only got like hundreds of
knowledge nuggets
which is seemed kind of small and then
in addition to that okay size we can
measure but what about relative weights
were strength the differences were speed
differences and these are visual to
human eyes not really for computer
vision yet to some degree yes but not in
a reliable way that I could depend on so
our revised the pool and Dan is that
well I mean one could just wait but
since we don't have anything better to
do let's go back to language but with a
different plan so key insight is this
even though nobody says any of this
people do say that they throw a pen or
stone chair and so forth so all of these
are possible when the agent is typically
bigger than
object heavier than the object as a
result the object is moving faster than
the agent temporarily so the
representation which we named as a verb
physics goes as a follows for it's a
very similar to semantic frames frame
semantics but it now talks a little bit
more about pragmatic meanings of
language so for any pair of potential
arguments of a predicate we can think
about what may be implied so we walked
into the house may imply that I am
probably smaller than my house and
lighter than my house and moves faster
than my house and if I squash a bug with
my boots
probably my boot is next with Y oh yeah
squashing a bug with my boat and my the
bug is smaller than my boat and lighter
than my boat and so forth so they are
this sort of a long list of obviously
likely truth about the world that comes
to our my our mind and perhaps we can
learn to detect that as well so in terms
of model we decided that perhaps we can
solve two related the problems is
simultaneously in particular physical
properties implied by verbs so what kind
of actions to imply about different
arguments and then also in general
different relative knowledge in between
objects across the five different
attributes in this work although one can
extend it to include other attributes as
well and if you have been waiting for
deep learning to pass so in this work we
didn't use a deep learning per se
although we did make use of neural
embeddings but otherwise it's a factor
graph with lots of variables that have
probabilistic interpretation so
it goes to something like that I'm going
to give you a very sketch idea of what
we are doing so we are going to throw in
a bunch of the random variables so that
might mean that for each of them it
might mean something like P is either
bigger or smaller comparable to Q in
terms of a size so they can have this a
three different value assignment and
then on the other side of the graph we
can also throw in a bunch of the random
variables that are in cause action
implications again the value can be
there bigger or smaller or same and then
there can be about a particular predict
you like throw with respect to a
particular attribute like size in fact
this predict variable is a collection of
random variables internally due to the
fact that using the same verb like throw
we can use in many different frames so
we just use different random variables
for different instance she ation of any
particular predicate but for now we
might just assume that they're sort of
like behaving similarly now at this
point though there's no evidence about
any of these random variables truth
assignment because nobody says my house
is bigger than me and nobody says when I
throw something I am usually bigger than
the object
no one says any of this so the only
thing that we do observe from language
is how people use different arguments
together with the different actions that
for example I threw my bag as I walked
into my house so people do say this and
that's the relational evidence is the
only evidence that we do have so sort of
translating this intuition into the
graph model is that what we are throwing
in potential function that quantifies
the selection of preference between a
verb and its arguments and then
similarly a lot of potential functions
for object obj2 similar
as well as verbal similarity as well as
a friend frame similarity and then
finally we cannot suddenly decode
knowledge out of nothing so there's a
little bit of asset knowledge given as
unary potential function so that we can
reason about the entire network and so
far we've been only talking about sighs
well we can keep doing this until the
network gets very very messy by adding
this weight part and other parts as well
so there's this well-known inference
algorithm known as loopy belief
propagation that's what we did for
making the inference and the conclusion
very briefly is that the random
assignment will be 1/3 accuracy majority
baseline will be about 44 to 50 whereas
if we just use noodle embeddings to
reason about different knowledge without
the entire graph about just one node
independently from all the other then
that's how much we do and then having
this graph inference can help improving
the performance further and on one side
we are looking at frame predictions on
the other side we are looking at object
object knowledge so to summarize we have
explored whether it's possible to
reverse engineer novel physics knowledge
from language even though people don't
speak the obvious effects but perhaps we
can design a model or inference
algorithm that could still be able to
reason about unspoken but what we all
assume with each other which
systematically influences the way people
use language which then give us some
clue about what may be true about the
world and we can do this without having
robots that can have an embodiment and
interact with the world all right so now
I'm going to conclude with some remarks
about what kind what future future
research directions we might pursue
further
so as far as neural network architecture
there have been some debates about
whether there should be innate
architecture or not I'm obviously on the
side of having innate architecture I
think Indiana pit community there have
been more emphasis relatively speaking
more emphasis on the linguistic sentence
sentential structure where there use
usually are some explicit structure and
it's very very well studied whereas the
moment we start thinking about document
level or discourse level were just
generally long term context or latent
processes of how the world works things
have become much less clear how to
handle this nonetheless I think this
part is very important to pursue further
and then as far as the formalism I think
we should really start thinking more
about like what to do with the common
sense I was told not to use the word for
sometime and I think it's because it was
major failure before but I realized at
some point that it's just nonsense to
conclude that that direction is going to
be forever impossible when the past
failures were based on weak computing
power not much data no crowdsourcing and
not much computational as a strong
computational models and also it was
done by non NLP people I'd and I think
with language we can do a better job or
we should try before concluding that
it's not going to work so in terms of
physical common-sense the potential
impact cases could be more with zero
share future reasoning cases especially
when there's a language and vision and
robotics applications but we can also do
similar things with the social common
sense which I haven't talked about today
however we've been working something
along this line with commutation frames
and also we now have new ASL paper
coming up which I'm going to give you a
teaser about so it's going to be about
based on the Roc stories developed at
Microsoft and Rochester where the story
goes like this the band
instructor told the band to start
playing he often stopped the music when
players were often they got tired to
study the playing worse after a while
and so forth so when they're already
sort of people involved in a story we
can oftentimes the reason about what
people might feel like here the
instructor was a furious and threw his
chair it doesn't mean to say what these
guys feel now about that situation but
we can imagine that they must fear feel
fear or feel angry were said even though
it's not mentioned here so we can sort
of have this annotation very low level
of notation about what people might feel
what people's motivation might be before
and after different actions and events
and we have a bunch of new annotations
and baseline models reported coming up
soon and then related work also in ACL
will be about common sense inference for
example if someone cooks Thanksgiving
dinner probably that person's intent is
to impress their family afterwards maybe
they will feel tired but still feel a
sense of belonging and finally other
people even though they are not
mentioned in the sentence they will
probably feel impressed or happy and so
forth so we can reason about what people
might typically do before and after in
terms of their mental states so it's
also coming up at ACL with a bunch of
new data set so finally I thought or
said that this new epic new modeling
power those creators is some new
opportunities for doing more human
centric applications so that people
don't fear just AI has a negative
potentially scary thing I think we could
try doing more positive acts in that
space personally I think we should work
more on interactive AI because that's
what robotics people really want as well
and especially the neural network is
so that we can do a lot of creative
things in text regeneration too so I
will just read in this so net that was
generated by a machine so Turing was the
title and it goes like this creating
some a locked electric slot machine of
hearing those familiar voices say awake
behind an empty picture mean the window
is open over Alan Kay consider me of
regular expression or maybe something
very quickly typed and I forget about on
old obsession a hundred thousands people
getting hyped become the biggest part of
my computer and take another journey
down the road or set a balance on a
minor scooter or even better whose
Enigma code and music takes control of
all the means is surrounded by a world
of strange machines couldn't fool
anybody yet thank you thanks very much
for an awesome talk agent we have about
five minutes for questions so I'll run a
mic
I had a question and I wanted to know
your thoughts on so fashionable titus
previous there was work done for open
sight or the psyche knowledge base which
is to encode common sense knowledge and
a knowledge graph and I was wondering
about your thoughts my utility of using
that for possibly distant friends so hey
I think there have been some couple are
kind papers that I tried to use at least
concepts an edge which is maybe is
analogous to open sight and try to see
whether it can improve some downstream
applications right to a and Intel mount
and the dialogues so it's a great
question personally I didn't look at
open sight but I heard from other people
who did look at that that it's very much
easy or hierarchy so it's a very
dictionary knowledge or taxonomy
knowledge concept net which I did look
myself it's also a very taxonomic
knowledge or predominant with that they
do have a lot of other relations that I
really appreciate and find a very
interesting unfortunately coverage on
those more interesting cases are a
little bit lacking so which sort of a
motivates our new data set that tries to
cover like motivation is for example
included in the concept net relation
definition however the coverage is
relatively small and so it's one way to
increase the coverage eventually it may
be useful but we'll have to find out
supervised learning using humor and
annotated like data that and is the hope
that you can use this with the correct
architecture to create you know to help
the system to be able to in general
understand how to make these types of
inferences yes
so what we do show in the paper is to by
using very encoder/decoder architecture
basically almost of that we can learn to
encode any textual description of event
and then reason about what might happen
to people's mental states such that
given a previously unseen event
description in the test dataset it can
still reason about what's likely mental
state which is what we basically have to
be able to do and if we are using all
the fashion the logic base the systems
then that wouldn't work it then there
has been knowledge populated for
everything whereas with the neural
network we can learn to compose the
likely anticipation instead of having to
crowdsource literally all of it which i
think is just not possible maybe we have
time for one more quick question before
before the end of this session so how do
you know that when when you're done as
in how do you measure coverage recall
like you can measure precision but what
about recall so in this particular work
we have a sort of like test set cases
where you know test two cell starts with
this left hand side of the logic and
then we try to predict the right hand
side but I wouldn't be able to say in
terms of like recall with respect to
everything that I ever know of I
wouldn't know yet maybe if we start
thinking about it someone will come up
with a number but thanks once again
Yujin
you